Lawmakers say the US is not
adequately prepared to
defend against cyberattacks launched by
other countries or by criminals as
demonstrated by this latest attack against
one of the largest fuel networks
that supplies almost half of the
gasoline, diesel and other fuels
used.  in the south and east of the country
this cyber attack is not the first
of its kind last year for example
there was another attack against the company
solarwinds the us government
now says that russian spies had
access to information from
private companies and nine federal agencies
during  over eight months
government officials say it is clear the
country needs to do more to protect itself
sarver 4 senator kerry peters says the
us also needs a new
cyber warfare strategy as
he believes countries like china and russia will
continue these attacks
there is currently a proposal in the senate that
would provide 20
million  is dollars over a
seven-year period to help combat
cyberattacks but
lawmakers say the problem is
bigger than a lack of funding and
point to a lack of communication and
lawmakers from both parties say
they are concerned that some
federal agencies were not  completely
honest about how much information was
compromised in last year's attack
reporting in washington alexandra limón